字幕: Jiayu LIN
校正: Hiroko Kawano
想いは 目には見えません
失恋して悲しいとき
人を傷つけてしまって
罪悪感に喘ぐとき
自己嫌悪で凹むとき
胸のチャックを開けて 友達や家族に
自分の想いを見てもらえるなら
楽ですが できません
誰にも分かってもらえませんし
誰も あなたを分かることはできません
そこで 見えない想いに 見える形を与え
外に引っ張り出して 人に通じさせる行為
これを｢表現｣と言います
私は表現教育を 使命としています
想いは 音楽に表したっていい
絵に描いたって ダンスだっていいんですが
あなたのすぐ傍にあり
誰でも今日から出来る表現手段
それは 書くことです
見えない想いに｢言葉｣という
誰の目にもあきらかな形を与え
外に引っ張り出して
人やに社会に通じさせていく
これが｢文章表現｣
書くことです
あなたは「書く」という
想いを形にする装置を持っている
「はい」と言えなかった事はありますか？
友達からSNSで
「これ拡散して」と頼まれたとき
就職活動で親や先生から
「こっちの会社にしなさい」と言われたとき
「はい」といえば収まるのに
なぜかどうしても「はい」と言えない
そんな時 あなたの中に
「想い」があります
想いは 今この瞬間にも
あなたの中に生まれ
知らぬ間に育っていきます
私の中に想いがあると気付いたのは
会社に勤めて 16年目でした
その日まで
私は全国に５万人の会員を持つ
高校生向けの小論文教育の
編集長をしていました
しかしその日
人事異動を言い渡されたのです
全く違う部署に行くに当たって
異動先の上司は私にこう言いました
「山田さんの16年の編集経験を
全部捨てて 頭を真っ白にして
うちに来ること｣
マニュアル化が進んでいたのです
会社は急に大きくなって
人の出入りも激しくなっていました
ベテラン編集者１人に頼った物作りでは
その１人が抜けたとき
ガタガタになってしまいます
ですから 人が入れ替わっても
２年目や３年目の若い編集者たちでも
常に 一定の物作りが出来るシステム
それを 異動先は作ろうしていたのです
私は「はい」と言おうとしましたが
何故か どうしても
「はい」という事が出来ませんでした
会社で 人事異動を断るとは
辞めることを意味します
春からの体制に邪魔をしないよう
円満に会社を辞めるためには
４日で決断をしなければなりません
そうなってみて初めて
何だか分からないけれど
私の中に動かし難い
「想い」があることに気がつきました
想いは お腹に宿った胎児のように
とても生命力が強い
反面 とても脆い
想いと裏腹な行動をとったことは
ありませんか？
想いは自分の物でありながら
実は 自分でもよく分かっていない
たとえると 想いは
あなたという氷山の 目に見える —
言葉でボンボン出てくるような表面には
ありません
ぶっちゃけて出てくるような浅い層にも
まだないんですね
あなたの深い 深いところ
まるで地球で言うと マグマのような所に
あなたの想いはあります
文章表現の用語で
あなたの最も根幹を成す
思想 価値観のことを
「根本思想」と言います
ですから 自分の想いが
何なのか知るためには
自分に問う必要があるんです
自分に問う —
これが「考える」ということです
会社を辞めるか 残るか決める
運命の４日間
私が唯一つやったのも
この「考える」という事です
考える道具は「問い」です
テーマに対して
有効な問いを立てて
自分の中の見えない想いを
言葉にして 引っ張り出すのです
私は いつも高校生たちと
一緒にやっているように 問いかけました
まずは 視野を過去へ —
今まで生きてきて
あなたが一番いきいきしているのは
どんなときですか？
私は小論文の編集者になって
最初の10年
高校生たちは
みんな同じような文章を書き
一向に 自分の想いを書けるようには
なりませんでした
しかし 11年目
文書を書く前の考える作業を
丁寧にやらせたところ
赤ペン先生も驚くぐらい
見違えるほど伝わる 実感あふれる —
一人ひとりまったく違う文章を
高校生たちが 書き始めたのです
これが 在職16年で
わたしが最もいきいきした瞬間
次に 視野を現在へ
今の社会に照らしてみた時
自分がやってきたことは
どんな意味があるのだろう？
当時 社会は
メールを使うようになっていました
みんな書いて想いを
伝えないといけないので
誤解されたり
すれ違ったりしていました
私がやってきた書く力の教育は
時代の中でますます求められている
最後に 視野を未来へ
５年後 10年後
理想が実現できるとしたら
あなたは 人や社会が
どうなっていったら良いと思いますか？
私は 「自分の頭で考え 自分の想いを
自分の言葉で表現できる —
そんな人が１人
また１人と増えていったら
日本はもっともっと面白くなる」
と思いました
４日目の朝 目覚めたら
「会社を辞める」
私の中に答えが
はっきり出てました
あなたが後悔していることは
なんですか？
未来は誰にも分かりません
なので 何が正しい選択か
間違っているのか
未来に行くことのできない人間には
知ることが出来ません
でも 表現教育を通して
たくさんの人を見てきて
ひとつだけ これは言えます —
それは
「想いに忠実な選択をしたとき
人は後悔しない」ということです
振り返ると 私はこれまで
小学校 中学校 高校 大学 会社と
ただ 箱を乗り換えるように
選択をしてきました
今の箱を 押し出される段になって
慌てて 次の箱の選択肢を
あたふたとかき集め
どっちが上か どっちが有利かと
選択肢を比較して
何かを択び採ってきただけでした
生まれて初めて 想いの底から
「こう生きよう 会社を辞めよう」
と決めた
朝の風景はそれまでと
まったく違って見えました
風が透き通って 気持ちいい
木々も 光も
今生まれたばかりのように
私にはいきいき 輝いて見えました
空は悲しいぐらい
どこまでも どこまでも澄んでいて
痛いぐらい美しい 朝の風景でした
書くことは 考える力を育てます
そして 考えることこそ
あなたらしい選択へと導くのです
会社を辞めた私に待っていたもの —
それは一言でいって
「繋がりの危機」でした
私は 社会と直接繋がっていた訳では
ありませんでした
会社という箱に所属することで
間接的に
社会に繋がっていただけでした
だから会社を辞めたら 易々と
社会との繋がりも切れてしまいました
今まで 私を生かしてくれた
社会的居場所 —
上司がいて 編集部の仲間がいて
全国の高校生がいて スタッフがいて
そのすべてを失ったとき 私は泳ぐことも
息をすることも出来なくなりました
小論文の編集長として 高校生の
考える力 書く力を生かすことは
私という存在の支柱でした
その支柱が折れてしまうと
私はグラグラし 自分が何者かも
次第に分からなくなっていきました
昨日の私は 今日の私ではない
今日の私は 明日の私ではない
連続性の危機 つまり
アイデンティティーの危機です
朝 目覚めるたびに
じわじわと 自分の輪郭が
縮んでいくのが分かりました
そんな崖っぷちの私を
支えたのも書くことです
インターネットに週に１回
コラムを書くことを始めました
「インタネットでこれを読んだ
１人の人の表現力 伸びろ！」と
私の経験のすべてを
捧げるように書きました
時には 自分がグラグラして
苦しいので
「苦しい！」という生の声
それも書きました
「でも もう一回 教育の仕事をするんだ！」
志も書きました
書いて書いて 書き続けて
いつしか 私にはたくさんの読者がついていた
その年の暮れ
初めての本の依頼が来ました
今一番言いたいことは 何ですか？
初めての本は文章術の本 —
７ヶ月かけて書きました
でも７ヶ月かけて 何度書き直しても
最後の最後の言葉が
どうしても書けませんでした
とうとう この日に書かないと
出版に間に合わないというギリギリの日まで
私はボロ雑巾のようになって
朝から晩まで
たった数行 書いては消し
書いては消し[を]しました
土壇場のギリギリの時
「私の最初の本を読む 一人の読者に
何が言いたいか？」と考え詰めたとき
この言葉が 腹の底から
湧き上がってきたのです
「あなたには 書く力がある」
「ああ これ 会社を辞めるとき
あの時 私を突き動かした想い —
ずっとずっと私の根にあったマグマだ」
という風に分かりました
喜びがこみ上げてきました
次の瞬間
「あっ これ 私」と思ったんです
所属がなかろうが 肩書きがなかろうが
それがどうした？
向かう一人の表現力を伸ばす —
これが私だ
過去も 今も
未来にどんなに形を変わっても
私は書くことを通して
自分の繋がりを取り戻しました
そのようにして 私は書くことで
まず一人の読者と繋がり
次にまた一人 一人
次第にそれはネットワークになって
クモが 自分の腹から糸を出して
巣を張るようにして
コツコツと 社会に自分の居場所を
切り開いていきました
３年後
今度はフリーランスとして
私は 社会と
へその緒を繋ぐことができました
表現のゴールは「解放」です
自分の想いが これ以上ないぐらい
ピッタリした言葉で表せた —
人と通じ合えたというとき
人間には 深い 内的な喜びがあります
それだけではありません
あなたは「理解者」を得ます
文章を書いて通じ合える人 —
その人は あなたの表面を
見ているのではありません
断片的でもありません
あなたの想いの理解者なのです
書くことは苦しい
でも書き続ければ いつか
理解の花が降るような
そんな風景をきっと
あなたは目にするでしょう
書くことの喜びは
もうひとつあります
まだ 現実にないものも
人は書いて作る事ができる
そう 「創造」です
私は今 ４つの大学で
文章表現の授業を持っています
全国各地を 表現力育成の
ワークショップをしてまわってます
私の本は翻訳されて
海外に羽ばたいていきます
その先々には 自分の頭で考え
自分の想いを
自分の言葉で表現できる人が
一人 また一人と
増えていっています
あの会社を辞めたとき
私に何もないからこそ
「未来にこうなれ」と
願いをこめて書き続けた文章 —
それが今 現実のものとなっているのです
無いものを
あなたは書いて作ることができる
書く力を鍛えれば
あなたはこの現実というキャンバスに
自分の想う人生を
書いて 作っていけるのです
ですから 人は何度でも
何度失っても 立ち直ることができます
かけがえのない物を失ったって
居場所がなくったって
自分が失いそうでも 大丈夫
あなたの中に「想い」がある
そしてあなたは 想いを形にする
すばらしい装置を持っている
今これを聞いてるあなたに
私は最後に伝えたい
あなたには 書く力がある
ありがとうございました
（拍手）